welcome to see you're playing I must say
your chick from the US no name a six
yeah this is sir this is a line actually
sorry yeah this this deal with c5 and
and stuff wow wow really
okay there are openings under the Sun
what exactly is this this idea here I
know can I kill I refute this like
immediately
I know Queen D 425 this Bishop b4 that's
that's not the refutation I don't know
okay Bishop c5 no I D for probably
wasn't great
hmm 96 yeah what a stupid idea I really
hadn't paid attention to Bishop d7 who
is very very dangerous very dangerous
now
your queen d-force
amazingly idiotic it's probably really
the worst possible move besides i accept
some some direct blunders committee form
yeah hey what should be on the ropes i
can at least take with the good position
yeah I am
I think it can just take the tune as a
simple solution I know I have age flags
I'm sorry of course not age wings but
this is in fact quite helpful yeah if
you cannot cannot take on the tool
immediately then it might maybe it
wasn't such a brilliant idea the screen
age for business
okay he's returning and now the Bishop
p.m. yeah takes Bishop g2 with maybe
maybe really a threat
to capture here f3 looks amazingly bad
yeah I really hate to play this position
it's just too terribly without any
harmony probably just very bad maybe I'm
holding let's see seven assistants we
were taking him and it maybe just
returned how bad is it really as it is
it so bad
I've got a king on d2l that's how bad it
is and no time let's of course also a
substantial problem
okay
so he was satisfied with just kidding
getting the pawn back of course black is
black is fine here but I had really the
fear that I've made it co claim and this
at least didn't happen maybe I can trade
off some stuff I've got the king in the
middle which now in suddenly decides
learning looks so bad
I know step by step gets outplayed
really sorry dude really the problem is
I've got 58 seconds why does at least
more comfortable here our plate is too
strong a word but I'm absolutely not the
worst anymore
I can take here and take it 6-2 Bishop
Bishop before Jack yeah this happens
with no time on the clock
maybe Bishop here I can do 97 it's a
pure coincidence but still playable
here rookie 6 is interesting and Bishop
d5 I cannot follow up on that okay not a
problem
yeah I want to push the pawns of course
yeah very very tricky position the ship
f2 it's not on and now I have rook c1c
aid that's the possible way to go
group on the sixth would be nice over
here
oops
it coming
yeah I'm straightening rook a seven no
and this also rook a 88 queen coming
check check check check check check
checkmate oh no no no no oh my god what
a sick game I just thought whatever I
mean why is he even continuing Queen b6
winning the rook or whatever okay I just
I just put any move on the board and I
really didn't look anymore and I have no
way to avoid it yeah it's it's just made
into it's not even King bee - yeah what
a sick game
yeah he completely did not want to put
me away
especially weirdest is the Queen trade I
mean why would you track the Queen's
keeping the Queen's on the board it's
just with the King on be to just Queen
some way I'm b7 season I mean black ass
is better here as well but it's just far
far less of a problem here I'm already
close to equal with the King no playing
yet yep here blackest is already an IB
five is just I don't know don't know
what here white is just just clearly
better and I just need to avoid Knight X
is 6 cm just king degree and then
playing with those pesos
this is very nice for white and this is
not really a problem but it wasn't
helping that much tonight Luke c1 is
probably better you yeah here it was a
tactical tactical fight with some errors
on both sides I guess I mean white white
is winning according to the comments
it's very tricky to play can easily a
screw up self-made I can also go to c3
which is of course the better decision
or here to be one it's really the only
way to learn to still lose this it's
made in three actually but this this is
just great okay I hope you you had to
laugh as well
ah thanks for watching